i have to say first and foremost the
book is beautiful
thank you it's beautiful in so many ways
and i didn't expect
actually i i expected probably to cry
and get emotional
i didn't expect for that to be on page
three yeah
i'm serious i was with you from the
beginning a few years ago
my mother got sick and she had to have
surgery and i was here
got the news i fly back i'm rushing back
and i
i identified so much with you talking
about that walk down the hallway like
what it's like
how many steps you take how everything
seemed so
tunnel visioned you know it was it was a
lot just in those first few pages so
i was thinking to myself my gosh how
could she
relive all of what you went through like
in this book you know you kind of went
back and replayed it all when you're
writing this
yes oh my gosh it was um definitely
so emotional and you know it
it was so in my head though do you know
what i mean like
i really don't think i could write this
book now because
everything was so in my brain the
medicines the operations the room
numbers the doctors the
you know what levels everything should
be at it was just like so present
it was so right on the tip of my fingers
you know
why did you decide that you did want to
write a book i mean we had
kind of all followed your journey but
was it in a way to maybe cement
nick's memory in a way i never even
thought of writing a book
it was lisa at harpercollins she reached
out to me and she said you need to write
that story down
this this is a beautiful story i've been
following it i'm one of the people that
are singing with you every day and
praying for you every day and this story
needs to be written down
and i remember i was walking out of the
hospital and i was just kind of like in
a fog
and and like okay okay and
and then i thought you know what if i do
this i have to do with my sister
my little sister anna who was with me
throughout
this whole journey and you know knew
nick and i in
in new york and was just kind of like
always our third wheel in our
relationship and i thought if i
if i do this i have to do this with her
it's interesting that you were saying
that because as heartbreaking as
the book is um i really saw it as a love
story
in a lot of ways it really was um so i
kind of want to start at the beginning
of your love story
with nick and taking me back to when you
were both in bullets over broadway right
and that first meeting because i'm a
romantic i kind of believe
like you see somebody you're like oh
yeah that's where i'm supposed to be
well you know it actually took us a
little while nick and i
i mean i of course you know saw him
right away he was six foot five right
and you know tall dark and handsome if i
do
but i wasn't really looking at the time
and we really just became friends
first and we would just have really
great conversations after the shows you
know after broadway you get out of your
show you have all this energy and
adrenaline and usually you
go to the bar next door and have a drink
and food and wine down
and so nick and i kind of just became
friends and we started talking to each
other and having just really great
intimate conversations
we just sort of started connecting in
that way first and foremost
and then fell in love then you know his
talented singing acting and tapping
skills you know won me over
you know we we knew what we wanted in
the end you know we knew we wanted to
be parents one day we knew we wanted to
have a home one day we
we had beautiful end goals together and
so i think that that kind of always got
us there but
yeah i wouldn't say we had you know this
perfect love we had a really
deep perfect love we really kind of
loved and appreciated each other
i think another you know beautiful theme
that came out of your experience
um was the fact because social media can
be so mean
and so crazy and so divisive but it was
galvanizing for you
and it lifted you in so many ways
i honestly could not have gotten through
this journey without my social media
virtual army
that came together i mean not only this
like the daily 3 pm
singing and dancing with me which was
always something that lifted
my spirits
even on days where i was it would be
like 2 58
and i would think i can't do this right
now i have cried all day
and i'm exhausted and this is the last
thing i want to do
i would do it and then three minutes and
13 seconds later i would be in a
completely different mood because i had
15 000 people or 30 000 people
singing with me and going you can do
this he's gonna make
it code rocky and i'd just be like
that's right
all right who am i calling now i mean it
just was like this
support system every single day i mean
it got me through it still is getting me
through
every single day mickey boy
little steven is playing you on the
radio
i thought it was a beautiful just
positive way to present social media for
sure
especially in a moment where we need
some reinforcement
that humans are kind when we've gone
through the craziness
of this year and a half and where we all
felt so alone absolutely yeah
i know that sarah michelle gellard
rallied for you how did that lift you
oh my gosh i mean yes there was one
night we were eating sushi
and i looked at anna and i go
sarah michelle keller and freddie prince
jr bought a sushi tonight
and we were like you know our inner
teenage girls were like
oh my god jennifer love you and called
me and we were talking on the phone
i mean it was amazing but the thing is
is like those two especially jennifer
long and sarah michelle they're both
moms
and um they just i feel like they just
knew that i needed massive help and
they're both helpers and they knew they
could help
and they knew that they had the
resources to help and they just
jumped in and and as soon as i got on
the phone with either of them it felt
like i'd known them for years
it was amazing i mean to all of the
celebrities that reached out to me it
was so kind of everyone just to offer
any kind of help and support that they
could this is the first time that i'm
seeing
our book uh in book form
you let us in so much throughout the
journey but what was the toughest part
of putting this down
in a book honestly i think just
writing it i mean there were days that i
was writing
you know i would i couldn't write until
i put elvis down my son for bed so i'd
put him down for bed i'd finally eat
dinner and then i'd open my laptop up
and i would start writing it would be
like eight o'clock at night
i had been already up since you know 5
30 with elvis so i was exhausted
and then you have to go into like that
deep emotional space of writing this
story down
there were nights that i just i was
crying so hard i couldn't even see the
keyboard
i mean it was just kind of like like you
said before reliving all of this and
then also
not even the pain of reliving it but
just also
knowing that it's over do you know like
that we won't have more memories we
won't be able to make more memories
it didn't set in right away that he was
gone
and writing this story down kind of
really kind of made me feel like okay
this has happened you named the book
after one of his songs
why'd you decide to do that gosh you
know
nick this was nick's first single that
he released
and it became the anthem for my family
for his family i think for
all of my you know virtual army over
these 95 days
and then because we were in this
pandemic i think the title
of this song live your life was just
kind of like this
motto for everyone to be so grateful for
what we
have and for not taking a day for
granted not taking a second for granted
not taking a person for granted i
i was gonna say like listening to you
talk about it now i don't know are you
out of tears are you out of that do you
still have those days
when it yeah yeah i you know um
i saw a beautiful image about grief the
other day how
uh grief is us this size ball right
let's just say this size ball
and there's like six jars and the image
basically shows how
in the beginning of grief you're a small
jar around this big
ball and then as you know time goes on
the ball doesn't change the size of
grief never changes i will
never not miss or cry
about this situation but it says a
beautiful sentiment about how
you grow around grief because i think
the misconception with people is oh it's
been a year
right you're doing better you know you
don't you're fine right you don't miss
your person and that's like how could
you ever say that right like
it's no i mean of course you miss your
person
you've just grown around the ball
and um that size of grief doesn't ever
change
so many things to unpack about that 95
days
i remember reading and and where you
were talking about the beginning and i
felt like that was also so many other
family stories
of he was not feeling good but
didn't have all the symptoms you may
have heard about on the news so you're
thinking no way it could be coveted
maybe he's just
sick or we work a lot or or whatnot
how long did that go on before you said
no
no this is this is something else here
like a weekend a couple of days he was
literally just tired he didn't have a
cough he didn't have a fever um
there was nothing and i it even nick was
like i might have this and i was like
honey you don't
have this you're fine you're just tired
it was not and a symptom that anyone was
saying on the news and we were watching
the news like everyone else in america
24 7.
um it wasn't until after we went to
urgent care
they didn't give him a kova test because
he wasn't around anyone that was coveted
positive and at the time there were two
very kind of like solid rules to get a
covet test
you had to be around somebody that had
tested positive or you would had to have
the symptoms
of covid he didn't have either so they
didn't give him a test
he came back in the car and they said we
think you have pneumonia and we were
like
celebrating we were like oh yes
pneumonia i mean when do you cheer for
pneumonia
but we really like we're so happy and
then over that weekend
the breathing issues really kicked in
and he was even
more so lethargic i mean it took him
like a half hour to walk
three steps into the kitchen that's when
we both
got scared that's when i really got
scared you said in the book you
you wish you had never gone back to new
york you think it he contracted it in
travel
in like in route from one place to the
next
you know as you can imagine i have
wrapped my brain
a million times about trying to figure
out how and when and
how we could have caught this and even
the doctors are that
you know we talked about it in the
hospital and there's no way we'll ever
know
it is likely somewhere in new york or
somehow on one of the plane trips
here or coming back i don't we don't
know though but um
i don't know i mean sometimes yes you
know of course you go back and you're
like what could i have done differently
if we would have stayed in
la and just had a moving company pack
everything up with things have been
different
it's it's tough to say but maybe it's
hard to live in what ifs i know
when your world has changed so
dramatically
and it was really dramatic with him
because once he did go to the hospital
it was rapid yeah yeah yeah oh it was
crazy what had happened to nick in just
18 days
was there was one instagram post where i
listed everything and even
i remember writing it being like how
does
all of this happen to one person in 18
days and he's still alive
but how quickly your life can change
i just wanted to share because i think
that you know grief is important to talk
about
i do think though and as much as social
media has helped you
it can be a double-edged sword because
it's like sometimes you want to share
some things like i'm visiting
and the doctors are like no no no you
know what i'm saying so did you have to
learn some lessons and what to
yeah share and what not to share yeah
yes absolutely i mean there were things
that you know i kept private for my
privacy
a lot of things i kept private for
nick's privacy because you know he had
no say in any of this so i had to make
sure that i was respecting what i knew
he would want
kept private and then things that the
hospital asked me to keep private which
i
absolutely wanted to respect their
privacy so there were some things
i was just being so open that you know
i felt like it was okay that there were
some things that i kept to myself
and still to this day obviously you know
we share a lot of ourselves on social
media
but there's also a lot that for my own
safety for my son's safety for my
family's safety for next family safety
that i still keep private how did you
ever take care of you
i i worked out i worked out every day
fitness is my
go-to number one stress anxiety mental
health
like it was always a part of me and todd
and anna
my brother and sister who were living
with me made sure that i always did some
sort of workout
um every single day because they know as
soon as i pull out my jump rope put on
music
even if it's for 10 minutes i walk back
into the house in a completely different
mood
clear focused and and ready to go by the
way you show up on my equinox app every
day with your jump rope
i'm like if amanda and her jump rope
don't go on somewhere
like okay amanda i see you in your
[Laughter]
jumper
how are you managing now as a single
mama
i have a lot of help i have a lot of
help i couldn't do it without my help i
have five jobs
i'm working around the clock and um
and then i you know spend every single
second i can
with elvis but i've i have a great group
of friends that run to my
aid and rescue as much as possible and
my family my brother lives in san
francisco so he comes down to be with me
keep me company
um elvis and i have a really special
bond though i have
a really special bond he's a love bug
and i think that um i think we're going
to grow up to be
quite a pair and you do talk about kind
of how you're reinventing your life you
said you have five jobs one of them of
course is our neighbor
at the top why was this the right job
to take for you at this time yeah
well you know it's funny yeah i'm doing
19 living 19 years in new york city
um performing on broadway doing
television film
dancing as a radio city rocket you know
performing being on sets and things is
nothing new to my life
um even when i did my fitness business i
was constantly promoting it on morning
shows and talk shows so
again um walking on set and guest
co-hosting in october
on the talk just kind of felt like i was
at home
and honestly it's such a blessing
because i get to go
to a family every day and i get to have
conversations with four adults
something i don't get to do at home that
you would think
sounds maybe trivial no but not to a
single mom
who is otherwise talking about trash
drugs
so to go and spend an hour of my day
feeling good and talking about adult
conversations
is a lifesaver and i have a family where
i lost a family now i have a new family
it's been a godsend
finally um what do you tell elvis about
his daddy
oh i tell him so much i mean we you know
i
am just persistent on keeping that kid
aware that his dada is around we listen
to nick's music
all the time as soon as i put on live
your life he starts banging his head
like he's in a rock band it's the cutest
thing
um you know we have pictures of nick
everywhere he kisses this one every
night before we go to bed
um before i put him in his crib i tell
him you know the dreams that he's gonna
have and they always
entail nick taking him on some sort of
adventure
and we talk about nick all the time it's
it's hard to say you know because he's
not even two
um what he knows or what he thinks
but i do think that he knows the dada
somewhere
i think that nick comes and visits him
and spends time with him i really do
you